[Musik]
die zukunft ich habe mein video fertig
geschnitten kinder willkommen entlocken
es tag nummer 19 da eigentlich relativ
früh angefangen und dann hatte ich
plötzlich in zwei stunden gespräch mit
meinem steuerberater um ja richtig cool
ja der letzte bleibt jetzt nur zehn
minuten lang das für mich wie hat mir
geschrieben dass sie jetzt zu diesen
neuen blogs und diese arten nicht so
mögen und dass ein bisschen langweilig
finden bzw
jetzt auch die mir so gerne reinschalten
das finde ich auch vollkommen okay fühlt
euch nicht an der presse und meine
videos anzuschauen wenn ihr das nicht
machen wollt dann macht er es nicht ist
ja auch eigentlich nur noch bis
weihnachten gloggnitz wollte es ganz
klassisch machen einfach einloggen und
bis jetzt macht mir das auch spaß ich
bin sowas von überrascht dass jetzt der
heute ist und ich einfach noch
durchziehen
ich hab's wer mich länger verfolgt weiß
dass ich es jedes jahr ein ich versucht
habe und nie geschafft habe weil es ist
wirklich insane jeden tag zu schneiden
jeden tag zu drehen und hochzuladen ich
weiß ich drehe keine extra video
aber natürlich ist es was anderes wenn
man mit einer kamera spricht und immer
weiß so ich muss jetzt das mit der
kamera aufnehmen
eigentlich arbeite ich künstler stunden
zu sein aber ich möchte dass ich
erzählen weil ihr müsst selber hassel ii
misst alle arbeiten und ich bin nicht
dafür da um euch zu ziemlich schwer
gehabt ich wollte nur einmal mich selber
loben sehr gut gemacht war der saal bis
jetzt durchgezogen könnt ihr auch mal
machen glücklich meinen kommentaren
wirklich meinen kommentaren wird das
sehr gut gemacht
timo schminkt sich schon wieder mega
lange so eine coole der wissens
bastelladen und dann noch einkaufen und
das sind so sind antalya oder timo zu
lichten und ich dachte
heute sagen dass ich das versucht habe
die erste so ein bisschen auseinander
zufrieden und sie tatsächlich ein
bisschen besser ist es noch nicht
überall gemacht
aber ja wenn man sie so auseinander free
mit ein bisschen realistischer aus als
so wie ich es vorher hatte guten morgen
kinder zum blog miss tag nummer 20
willkommen zum glocken ist tag nummer 20
yohei läutet wir können gar nicht
glauben ich sitze gerade im auto ich war
bei rewe einkaufen und jetzt fahre ich
nach hause denn heute ist ein ganz
besonderer tag wir machen ganz viel ich
muss ganz viel basteln und es wird super
klasse ich werde kochen müssen dafür
entschieden weil sie warum heute
entspannter tag ist aber ich glaube es
liegt daran
ich glaube es liegt daran dass ich heute
nicht schneiden musste weil ich gestern
schon wieder viel zu wenig gefilmt habe
und dass kein blog wurde und ich gehe
jetzt heute um 17 uhr dann live quatsch
mit ein bisschen mit euch mit ein
bisschen und mit ein bisschen wenn ich
meine brille ist nur ganz bisschen
übertrieben aber ich mag sie
wenn ich so rumlaufen habe ich das
gefühl keiner kann mir war es und es war
ganz spontan dass ich mich entschieden
ab einkaufen zu fahren weil ich hasse es
allein einkaufen zu fahren ich weiß
nicht warum aber ich drücke mich immer
davor timo es eigentlich mal der der fan
muss bzw
nämlich kino immer mit oder war halt bei
team mit aber so alleine
kennt ihr das auch ich war so schlimm
sei die ist habe ich also ich habe es
hinter mich gebracht und das eigene geld
werden kann man sich ganz viel zeit
nimmt für die ganzen produkte schaut
sich noch jemand gerne die supermarkt
produkte an
danke bockiges kind hier sitzen schon in
den kommentaren warum also warum ich so
viel im haushalt macht und warum also
erst wir auch mehr machen könnte naja
irgendwie geträumt gespielt ganze
kürzlich ganze bei bizerba hat er sich
so in diese klippe reingelegt
ich habe mir gesagt das ist schon wieder
das ist doch gefährlich kommen wieder
hoch es ist ja gar nicht möglich konzern
also wie war nicht zusammen oder so aber
der war geständig verliebt ich keine
ahnung existiert in dieser welt nicht
seine welt nur eines nämlich dessen mich
hübsch süß und fanny der zu alles
bekommen so wie ich nur na das hat aber
auch süß empfangen bis auch extrem zu
mir zusammen absolut empfehlungen
der scheiben käse heute abend um 17 uhr
werde ich die gewinner mit stream
verloren und die sachen schon einpacken
weil ich hab gestern so wachs gekauft
und zum siegel zum zu machen und heute
kam noch mehr karten an ich jetzt noch
gestört dass er kein persönlicher gruß
groß drauf ist und ich habe mich in die
anderen verliebt bin ich ehrlich bin ich
ehrlich deswegen verlor sich so viele
von denen die wir zusammen gemacht haben
und heimlich alleine noch mal gemacht
aber da muss man heute auch alles zur
post sind nur das wird dazu hatte ich es
mir nicht an
vielleicht ja auch wenn ihr die queen
mochte sorry aber sie hat jetzt richtig
aus und bilderrahmen royale weihnachten
wünschen timo und vanessa oder so
übertrieben ist haben wir also ich habe
die rückseite noch ein bisschen cooler
gestaltet und im großen geschrieben und
dass die leute halt auszulesen haben
geil oder weil die ist vorne so richtig
dekorativ und weihnachtlich und hinten
so hey wir lieben und wir lieben euch
unser highlight dieses jahr der umzug in
der ersten
ich bin so dumm war nicht an dich
gedacht das waren um eine community aber
ja ich bin so dumm
ich habe ein meeting um 13 uhr gehabt
jetzt 13 uhr 14 und jetzt fahre ich da
hinten
wisst ihr ich hasse es dass man von
youtube man immer denkt dass die so und
verantwortungsvoll sind und scheiße und
am ende des tages stimmt einfach wie
youtube schaffe sich meinen termin
einzuhalten
ich weiß auch nicht warum ich glaube war
ich noch mit dem google kalender nicht
klar kommen sonst habe ich immer in
meinen kalender reingeguckt ingolstadt
für die gesundheit ortschaft aber nicht
so scharf wie du ich bin einer stunde
denk ich mal wieder da die wenigsten
[Musik]
stück wirklich stehen tatsächlich aber
ich wollte es nicht mehr warten
ich bin jetzt raus gerannt und ich hatte
einen termin mit stellt die fahrradtour
aber stell dich vor arthur also genau
und wir sind in unserem gemeinsamen büro
wir haben jetzt geheiratet
arthur ist nicht unser gemeinsames büro
naja vielleicht vielleicht wir machen
probezeit
ja wir probiert es mal aus ja ich werde
meine sachen in der ecke stellten okay
ach so wir probieren das mal aus mit der
linken hand damit jeweils diese
probezeit
achso assist von wenn wir dann
irgendwann wenn du dann
sie simulieren das jetzt immer guckt das
wäre doch das geschäft geschafft
ja ich bin jetzt gerade hier hat den
termin und wir uns zufällig getroffen ja
und ich konnte dir deine fest heute
wieder gegen weiss noch ja das war schön
oh wow motto das treffen was machst du
jetzt hier im podcast auf wir machen
nicht nochmal zwei tomate werden
ich habe schon etwas gebracht hat ich
mache gar nicht in 20 oder podcasts auf
platz 76 gerade der podcast chart 1 über
schwanz und schwanz möglich schwanz und
wie heißt du kennst du der schwank der
schwulen podcast schwanz und ehre oder
schwanz und wahrheit oder sogar vor
lassen
ich hab das kann geschenkt gekriegt
ja ich war oben im büro und haben sie
mir gesagt hey ich hab gerade als
kleines geschenk konnten hingestellt du
siehst müde aus es ist gut hier kann man
hier ist sehr gut
naja also nachbarin ist ein bisschen
sensibler wohnen 18 laut bist ja gut
aber das kann ich gern mehr machen die
leute wissen sie mit timo zusammen
[Musik]
es ist nötig aber dass er sich unsere
schulden ist ja weit weg wie bei
bewusstsein ja ich dachte deswegen ist
hier
wir haben darüber gesprochen dass wir
haben darüber gesprochen
oder was so lasst uns morgen schreiben
ja ok hattest du auch in das büro
gedacht nee nee das ist das am ende sein
wird ja es war eine wagen sind aber
solche was sagen sie mal durchgerechnet
ist gar nicht so viel wenn ich an so
viel steuer und davon keine steuern ja
und es ist auch gerne realistisch so
viel für sein büro und darum dass ein
hund aber wir müssen uns echt kümmern um
besseres internet es ist ein 50er ist es
völlig okay so aber gerade für streaming
denn drüben einer was hochlädt oder so
denn das baby kümmern sicherungs bessere
wir können ja keine glasfaser hier leben
können wir selber nicht machen
das müssen leute machen die sich damit
auskennen und auch glasweise haben
schöne aussicht zeige ich jetzt nicht
ausgehalten ist so scheißegal kommst du
arbeitest scheuklappen auf erfolg erfolg
wir versuchen ich versuche mein gott das
funktioniert super oh mein gott dass die
das cd aller zeiten
außer dass der brief nicht anbrennt ich
habe gerade dreieinhalb stunden
getrieben
es war einfach so cool ich weiß nicht ob
commodity streamen irgendwie ich glaub
ich hab dich nicht so eine leidenschaft
entdeckt für mich
ich habe mit kerzen gestreamt die habe
ich aber gebraucht mein trick man sich
hier gemacht habe und zwar habe ich
schon das sind noch nicht alle aber ich
hab' ich hab sehr viel post zugemacht
zwar so ein toller tag einfach nicht
zufrieden einfach mit allem das ist doch
schön oder man einfach zufrieden ist was
bringt einen mehr in weihnachtsstimmung
als dass kevin allein in new york im
hintergrund so die meisten leute haben
sich jetzt auf meine anfrage gemeldet
zehn leute noch nicht ich habe war schon
so viel mit adressen für geräte und es
ist mittlerweile halb also wieder meine
gewohnte zeit
ich weiß nicht wo der tag schon wieder
hin verschwunden ist
aber deswegen ist auch die
weihnachtszeit einfach so stressig ist
eigentlich schönste zeit im jahr sein
und am ende ist die stressigste zeit um
ja an geschaffen das wir schaffen das na
gut nicht einmal weiter
ja ich mache dann ja ich mache das jetzt
mal weiter ich liebe einfach
weihnachtsfilm im hintergrund schauen
und einfach sich berieseln lassen schon
schön
comteam
nein schade es geht aber immer noch aus
wie eine hochzeitseinladung ich will
nicht wissen wie viele leute geschafft
sein werden
aber okay wir sind eingefallen dass ich
ein paket bekommen hat
[Musik]
studio 71 hat mit dieser dinge geschickt
happy holidays von studio 71 liebe
vanessa wieder neigt sich das jahr dem
ende zu die hatten auch einen schlechten
stift der studio 71 foley thank you
create blieb auch mittlerweile so sehr
schwarze moody's ist einfach praktisch
zum anziehen
ich weiß nicht warum ich dachte dass es
mit der post schnell geht
natürlich sind jetzt stunden später um
17 uhr mit den briefen angefangen im
stream okay da muss ich noch die
gewinner aussuchen
dann habe ich so ungefähr bis 11 die
die vier stunden hier aber alleine zehn
stück für diese ganzen kartenverlosung
so gebracht das soll mal jemand
nachmachen
na ja und da hat sich damit fertig war
die post führt sofort vorbilder wird
freunde gekümmert also 40 briefe
eingepackt versiegelt dieses siegel war
in meinem kopf so cool und es ist auch
mega cool was ist so anstrengend diese
siegel darauf zu geben
eigentlich müsste ich heute ich dachte
ich schaffe heute zwei bilder noch zu
malen und jetzt ist es zwei und ich muss
morgen theoretisch und sächsisch
wiederau besteht das leben gerade darum
ein meckerte slate um zwei uhr morgens
immer noch ich habe angst dass dadurch
dass ich jetzt diesen stress habe sie
sich zurück in meiner alten panik
verfallen
also ich habe mit meiner sozialpädagogin
besten freundin gesprochen und sie hat
gesagt das wichtigste für einen gesunden
schlaf
das fand ich gut schlafen finde ich
sogar ich hab noch nicht mal heute
meinen adventskalender türchen
aufgemacht
meine augen drauf einstellen sie habe
nie gesehen wie ich meine augentropfen
partner jeden abend vorm schlafengehen
muss ich augentropfen nehmen dass ich
euch nie gezeigt wisst ihr was ich
nachhaltig ist grün start zu haben dann
nämlich jeden tag so eine ampulle
kleiner life hey ich kann das restliche
zeit aus der pulle in meine augenbrauen
rein machen weil das zeug gegen grünen
star ist das auch was bei wimpern
verlängerung drin ist also das ist eine
nebenwirkung
das sind kleine schon 2 und c ich habe
mir die karte hilft mir jetzt die
aufgabe eine gute körperhaltung versuche
den ganzen tag ihr bewusstsein auf ihre
haltung zu konzentrieren richte richten
sie ordneten gehörte auf ihren körper ob
sie sitzen oder stehen diese methode hat
eine sofortige wirkung erdung und stellt
aufmerksamkeit wieder her
das ziel besteht darin sich der
empfehlungen des eigenen körpers und
gegenwärtigen moment bewusst zu sein
okay leute
gute nacht
[Musik]
können